moi je suis pas un flic je suis pas un
maton où on va c'est un centre éducatif
fermé
vous êtes 12 attendre du jugement ça
dure six mois
regarde toi tu as compris les gones club
ici ça va être un gain de temps ce qui
ne prend pas pour un coût c'est bob
silas begin salle sécu les teddy votre
nouveau camarade quoi vous jouez à
renault ils s'appellent tejy vigueur
c'est à ma place moi c'est quoi les
places sont attribuées sa cible à leur
goût de la halle alors que la proie
voulez savoir pourquoi je suis là pour
de vrai que je prends vous aurez essayé
de voir pour ton bac d'accord parfait
certes toujours
et puisque c'est le top 60 savuth a pris
3 même vous êtes l'avenir de la vie
ensuite nous avons découvert le secret
benneteau
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est moi le boss
[Musique]